hey Conan here I'm at the Sirius XM
headquarters Midtown Manhattan as you
probably heard I'm about to launch my
own Sirius XM channel 106 Team Coco yeah
but I thought it was smart and I'm a
smart guy emotional intelligence stop by
Sirius first get the lay of the land
Find Out Who Your Friends Are Who your
enemies are step one
try and talk to people who've been in
the system for a while it's like when
you first get into a prison you go and
you talk to the toughest guy on the cell
block find out how to stay alive well in
my opinion that would be Madison here
Madison you are the host of two channels
that's right very popular channels
lithium also alt Nation alt Nation all
right give me some of the classic bands
that are on lithium and Alton okay
lithium it's not my fault that we play
corn do you like corn I it's been a
while I think corn was on my show back
in the day when I think corn I think of
the foot ailment we don't think of corn
the food no that's like fifth on my list
right right yeah so we play uh Stone
Temple Pilots oh yeah I love those guys
hey Weezer this is why I listened to
lithium all the time in all nation is
that a lot of these bands got their
start on my show did you ever have
Nirvana on they wanted desperately to be
honest you said no I listened to never
mind you know and everyone was talking
about it and I was like let's give it 10
years is what I said I believe in making
a band wait right so that's
unfortunately that's probably yeah who
knew but that was on me right
um I made a lot of bad decisions yeah
Alanis Morissette yeah hard I said no
not not gonna work not good I think we
did have Iran eventually yeah I put her
on as a stand-up comic and I did the
same thing with Stone Temple Pilots they
came on and they did a comedy sketch but
guess what shockingly not funny and now
he's dead nice going why do you keep I'm
sorry why do you keep bringing up that
people died are you putting that on me
no it's my fault that that people are
dead in bands it's it's lithium and
you're wearing your flannel so it's
perfect so yes lithium uh a lot of the
artists are dead unfortunately
you are the darkest person I've spoken
to in a while wait a minute everyone in
laser zone is Weezer though Weezer's
okay right
Wilson Rivers is alive for now
what are you talking about you can't
talk this is horrifying I mean no no no
I mean it's lithium they're they're they
were they were sad it's like talking to
the Grim Reaper hi Grim Reaper here on
lithium it's true I've claimed many of
these Souls they're all dead I'm here
with my scythe and my black hood it's
true and we're gonna listen to a bunch
of bands that aren't here anymore
you're very dark I love lithium because
I'll come out of an STP song
dead and I'll talk into a Nirvana song
dead do you get out a lot not a lot I
don't you have friends I
a few okay and you bring this up a lot
you'll hear a song on the radio and
they'll be like oh my God this is the
song I got engaged and you're like
they're dead maybe that's why they're
all dead yeah do you play that song
um by Crash Test Dummies we do on
lithium his hair and turn from black
into bright white
remember that once there was a boy who
couldn't eat an onion and he had to go
to school
that's where they're thinking about is
this a song or not
then they decided that maybe it is once
there was a girl who had to have some
soup but she didn't have a mouth that
song got into my brain I had them on the
show it got into my brain in like 94.
right and it's still there still sorry
I'll be urinating at three in the
morning sometimes at a toilet and I'll
be singing I'll suddenly just go his
hair had turned from black into right
way and my wife's like what the [ __ ] is
going on I'm curious about one thing
what where are you on the dial what
numbers 34 is lithium 36 alt Nation
how'd you get that number those numbers
are great all the best channels are in
the 30s you know what my channel is what
it's one oh six that's fine it's not
fine because it is it's good it's Conan
O'Brien this is a supposed to be a big
deal you're only five up from Howard
it's fine they were offering hobos 106.
and they wouldn't take it they're like
you can live on 106. there's a usable
bathroom you know who's higher up than
you no I don't know you're gonna feel
really good about this and I'm gonna get
in a lot of trouble for doing this so
this needs to be deleted you let us
decide what's deleted and what's not
deleted I don't want to lose my job
you're not going to lose your job I'll
take good care of it and if you do lose
your job I'm going to be on channel 36.
that's fine that's going to be the new
home of team does guess DJ play no no
Coco on channel 36 and then you can have
the wonderful food 106. the Chili
Peppers what about the Chili Peppers
want to know what number they're on what
number they
3 15.
you can't listen to the chili peppers
and drive safely you know what I mean
you can't when you're in your car and
you're driving and you turn on the Chili
Peppers in your hair that's happened to
bed today
[Music]
give it
give it away now
Ben it's a
little
bit
I'm running without a shirt remember
that one was running without a shirt
does he still do they still play with no
clothes on occasionally because at a
certain but not your shirt
what a certain point when a man
and I'm not saying anything derogatory
about flea I'm speaking of myself as
well but when a man gets into a certain
age range you don't want to see the junk
anymore right you know they don't show
their junk things are falling off
my left testicle fell off two years ago
I heard about that they did retrieve it
sewed it back on very happy for you yeah
well unfortunately on the same side it
was a bit of a mistake as the other one
so I have two testicles on one side and
then there's nothing on the other side
right but put your jeans on right it
actually works
I don't know how he got on this as long
as it wasn't your your dick
what's that nothing my dick how dare I
feel this is there an HR here
you're an HR serious oh please yeah I'm
talking to the host of lithium Channel
34 Channel 34. yeah oh no that's a great
Channel I know yeah she just mentioned
my dick and I feel triggered all right
listen
um
so you don't think the number's such a
bad thing no it's good I'm telling you
it's in all the cars it's in all the
cars it's there are cars that don't go
to 300 every car goes to one oh what is
it 106. oh yeah it really sticks in the
brain doesn't it only mention it like 15
times kidding I'm kidding let's say even
old Honda Accord or something ooh
how do you know that I don't drive that
I'm not wealthy like you please I've
invested very badly okay yes I did have
my access to some a lot of money at one
point yes and then I got into the I went
hard into theme restaurants Irish food
of the 1920s was my oh hannigans
chain I went big I lost 800 million
dollars
who knew that people didn't want to eat
depression-era food from Ireland
potatoes yeah it was just if you're
lucky
uh potatoes on a good day
half the menu was just various hard
Roots pieces of soil I can't take it are
there certain
hosts I should avoid be honest uh radio
people are dorks yeah that's what I've
kind of picked up on I come from I come
from the more sexy realm of late night
television right and hold on none of us
have hold on let me get myself back
again I tried to be cool and then it
just kept going I like you I like you
but I think we could be uh friends and I
think you could help me here at SiriusXM
and I'm going to come to you do you need
any advice yeah how do I get a better
number I want to be in the 30s do you
think it's possible okay I've I've got
it I know I know what channel you can
take what Hair Nation
what channel are they 39 39 you want to
know what they play on there a lot of
hair metal yes we're talking about
warrant Winger white lion all the W's
do they sometimes accidentally play
Wings thinking that it's never play
Wings well it's just it's they're in the
W's and they forget you know so wait so
Heritage is right these are closed
captioning
not
available
you go in this way and then here's a
nice feature the bathroom if you blew
that out it could also be a kitchen hold
on a second
and I say ask you one more question yeah
sure how come you say realtor on your
podcast I just do okay I know some
people want it to be realtor but I say
realtor I know you I choose certain
words and I put a little spin on them
and you know who else did that James
Joyce Ezra pound
Ernest Hemingway some of the greats you
take hold on Marie O'Connor Flannery
O'Connor you Jesus I gotta work this out
little things like that capture the
imagination what I want to do is I want
you to check in on me every now and then
I do want you to work on this channel 39
problem I'll try we have our plans
straight
Hair Nation no one gives a [ __ ] yeah we
move them out we move me in no one will
know everyone who listens is
57 year old alcoholic
on drugs every single person who listens
to her Nation I just all had this much
work done they look like that yeah they
have the hair is still yeah bleached I'm
realizing I just made really good
friends with someone who's going to be
fired there's no way you survive this is
all gone right oh God no you're this is
so [ __ ] right now I beloved yeah this
is gonna oh yeah after this riff about
those guys all alcoholics with [ __ ] up
faces thank you so much you're a really
cool person thank you so much I like
talking to you very much can I have a
picture it's not gonna happen